we're learning new details about the
death of George Floyd from new body
camera video that has not been released
reviewing by the public the new footage
is from the cameras of fired officers
Thomas Lane and J Alexander King those
were the first two officers to arrive on
the scene they've been charged with
aiding and abetting in the death of
Floyd the footage has not been shown to
the public for fear it could taint a
jury jeff McGee's is following the
investigation for us no Jeff good
morning what more can you tell us about
the video well good morning I spoke to a
reporter at our Minneapolis station WCCO
TV who saw that video and she says when
the officers tried to get Floyd into the
back of a squad car that's when the
situation there really deteriorated also
the body cam footage shows that one of
the officers pulled a gun on Floyd
shortly after arriving on scene
Floyd sounds upset and distraught you
can hear him repeatedly pleading with
the officers not to arrest him he tells
them he's claustrophobic when they
attempt to put him into the squad car
and you can hear a fearful Floyd say I'm
not a bad guy
the Floyd family has filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against the city of
Minneapolis and the four fire officers
officers Ben Crump is one of their
attorneys we seek to set a precedence to
make it financially prohibitive that the
police won't wrongfully kill
marginalized people Minneapolis city
officials are reviewing that lawsuit and
they say that they plan to respond to it
also the attorneys representing the
rookie officers Lane and King they say
that they want that body camera footage
out there because they believe it
presents a more complete picture of what
happened that day
Gail well the picture we have so far is
very painful and troubling this just
adds to that thank you very much Jeff